Hey,
what's going on?
Is Bill burn his time for the Thursday afternoon?
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast,
Dan.
Ah,
just checking in on you.
What's going on?
How's your week going?
Are you having a good time with the people in your life?
If you're not,
drink some booze.
Go down to the pub all by yourself.
Preferably during the day.
There's nothing better than day drinking.
I'll tell you that right now.
A lot of people think,
oh,
holding my child day during a disease.
I don't think so.
Shitting and a bar during the day,
you know one of those bars where you know the sun barely fucking comes in,
right?
One of those fucking places don't meet a gay bar.
All right,
let me tell you right now.
Now,
one of those gay bars were what's accepted now,
right?
Don't gay bars have like fucking ceiling.
The floor windows,
right?
We're here.
We're queer.
We'd like some fucking pairs.
Now.
What goes on there?
I don't know.
I haven't got caught up on will and grace.
I'm sorry.
That was a stupid mood.
Uh,
yeah.
Day Drinking,
day drinking.
But I always at the Beatles should have made that instead of day tripper.
She was a day drink.
Fucking booze it.
Yeah.
It took us
to get drunk.
Now she's drunk.
Boldo they [inaudible] do,
do,
do.
Um,
I've been writing all day.
We got a table read tomorrow morning,
so it's actually Wednesday evening and I'm doing this,
uh,
in my spotless home,
my spotless Ho,
Ho,
Ho home.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
My wife is on the road again.
Right.
She's out visiting some fucking friends or whatever.
Um,
or having an affair.
I don't know.
I can't keep tabs on her.
I only have an iPhone six,
you know,
if I had one of those phones that they already have in Japan,
I could probably watch it from a satellite and then texture,
you know,
while I played that creepy stinks on,
I guess it's the police.
Right.
I'll be watching you.
I remember I was sitting,
when that song came out,
they said,
uh,
you know,
that song actually makes men beat women.
It's like,
no,
I would say a poor childhood would,
would probably be bigger than stinks fucking song.
You know that was back when you really could try to blame musicians for fucking,
for your own bad parenting.
You know what I mean?
There was devil in the music and you play it backwards and you sucked as a
mother.
Well and then this Sean here reminds him of this and him dad.
Yes.
Small point.
It was in the womb to shut up already that Tipper Gore and all of them slapping
those stickers all over the place.
Right.
Meanwhile the and the Illuminati dressing up like pheasants stick in their
fucking fist in each other's asses all that's what goes down.
That's what happens.
That's the,
that's the kind of thing that CNN and Fox News are too afraid to talk about.
That's why they're always going after fucking comedians.
If we do a Bruce Jenner joke,
it's just a big misdirection cause they really don't want to know or let the,
the regular people know how much fisting is going on at the upper 1% of wealth.
But I'll get to that later.
I'll get to that later.
Um,
anyways,
that was a big weekend sport.
This is how little soccer fucking matters in the United States when Leicester
City did,
which is basically the impossible.
They won the premier league.
And I know there's a lot of yanks,
Laura Yankee cancellous and in right now.
Right.
Um,
basically the premier league,
in my mind,
in my world,
in my pasty freckled a lonely world,
I would say that the premier league,
if you're gonna watch soccer,
that's what the fuck you watch.
I would even say fuck the World Cup.
The World Cup is like the Saint Patrick's day of fucking soccer where every
douche bag who barely even gives a fuck shows up and then they fucking somebody
somebody gets puked on.
Right.
The Premiere League.
That's the real shit.
That is the real shit.
It just sounds real.
That looks real.
I ain't eight one.
I actually,
if I put that shit on,
if it's a little bit cold out,
you know,
it feels like that's Shitty fucking England.
Whether I'll actually watch it in,
which means a lot.
You know what I mean?
Cause I know the fucking people over in England,
they don't watch NFL football.
They think it's stupid.
Right.
Everybody running around,
you know,
in shape with good dentists dental work.
I'm sorry.
Um,
anyways,
so what I love about the premier league,
and I'm going to fuck this up.
It's been explained to me 50 times.
I just don't have enough time in my life to pay attention.
But the one thing that I do that I think is fucking hilarious is with all our
leagues over here,
if you're in the NHL,
you're in the NHL year in the NFL.
If you're in the NFL,
you just in there,
no matter how bad you,
you're fucking in there.
All right.
Like take the New York Yankees right now in the fucking
right.
I watched a little baseball this week.
Um,
I just happen to catch it.
I didn't even know the red sox are playing the Yankees.
Did we sweep them?
I think we did.
I think that made us go into first place.
Oh,
well my talking shit about a sport I never watched.
I think I am.
Um,
I actually liked it.
The,
uh,
the Panda Guy,
and I wish this on anybody,
but he's out.
So now we kind of don't really have any big free agents and I'll feel like the
Yankees really do either.
So I kind of like it.
It seems like it's gone back.
It's settled down the roids or right of the game.
All the big free agent fucking things.
It's just kind of settled down.
Um,
and this might sound fucked up to a red sox fan,
but I don't want the Yankees being last place.
I don't want to be right there,
right there with us,
you know,
slugging it out.
And then the last day of the year we give them the old right there,
Fred.
And then we go to fucking the playoffs.
That's what I want.
But I,
I'm,
I'm going,
I'm getting off the fucking highway here.
I need to get back on here.
So in the premier league,
this is a great,
that I think it's the last two teams,
the bottom two teams every year in the premier league,
if you suck,
if you suck the bag of Dicks,
basically,
if you just weren't,
everybody was kicking the shit out of you basically.
Meaning they scored like two goals on you,
you know,
it absent,
they got mad,
they lit up to goals and fucking nine hours.
Um,
they get bounced right out of the fear out of the fucking leak.
You know what I mean?
Like say a,
I don't know,
I'm trying to think of somebody and it's just so much parody in the fucking NFL.
We'll say the Tampa Bay Buccaneers back back in the day,
like when they went oh and 14,
boom,
you're out of the league,
you know,
and the Detroit lions,
you're out of the league.
And then they give,
they give some other clubs that chance.
And um,
and that happens every year.
And that's what I guess that's the way it becomes a premier league.
I don't know.
You'd think they'd just take all the best guys and stick them on 30 teams like
we do.
But this is different,
you know,
you'd think they'd brushed their teeth.
There's a whole bunch of things that you would think that they would do over
there,
but they choose not to.
You know,
it's funny,
I went over there,
I didn't really notice any worse teeth,
you know,
than they have over here.
Depending on where you're at.
I Dunno,
I just like breaking their balls and plus I'm going to be coming over there in
August.
It's looking like,
so I figure I might as well prime the pump by truck and shit about them.
God knows if I just said how much I enjoy going over there and traveling through
Europe,
if I said that,
that's boring.
So what you got to do to get people to come to shows as you got to shit on their
country.
Right.
So anyways,
um,
so after the end of the last last season,
two teams got kicked out and two new teams get brought in this little ass team
called Lester city right there.
Weird.
We're spelling it.
M God brought up and they were a 5,000 to one chance to win the whole fucking
thing.
5,000 to one.
Meaning if you put $1 on them at the beginning of the,
the thing you would have won $5,000.
You get it.
If you put $2 down,
all right,
you woulda got $10,000.
If you put 50 cents on those fuckers,
you woulda got $2,500 is that right?
Yeah.
Um,
anyways,
I'm just trying to say that doesn't make sense to me.
You wouldn't do that or what'd Ya mathematically does,
but in my head I just keep thinking five times one.
I'm seeing a five there.
I'll have to do it later,
but I think it's 20.
It's got to be $2,504 5,000.
I mean,
shit,
that's only fair.
All right.
So anyways,
plumbing your head here.
Um,
those motherfuckers one,
the whole thing.
I know there's a lot of people thought those one to two quickly.
Um,
I guess the US Olympic team in 1980 was like thousand to one,
and I forget what the mets were in 69.
Um,
but basically those were the two biggest sports underdogs and anybody could
think of in the u s or at least the person I was talking to and Leicester City
was five times that.
And,
um,
that was such a big fucking deal.
I actually went on the internet to see reaction videos of fans of that club
losing their fucking shit.
And I just sat there laughing in a good way,
seeing how happy people were.
Um,
that's always the grace.
I don't know why that is the greatest,
but it's always the greatest with somebody who just like out of fucking nowhere,
it comes along and wins it.
You know,
it's the whole rocky story,
right?
So congratulations to them.
Um,
but I think as much as that's the greatest sports thing in recent memory,
I think,
um,
in the U s we're going to eclipse that very quickly.
Uh,
if we haven't already,
because I have to,
I'd have to think what would the fucking odds that Donald Trump was going to
secure the Republican,
whatever the fuck the Republican National Convention Party,
whatever they call them,
they're not be the presidential nominee for that fucking party.
Do you understand that Ted Cruz
throwing in the towel and everybody said he elbowed his wife.
He didn't.
Okay.
She was third man in,
I tweeted about this.
If you look what happened,
he hugged her first,
right?
And then he went in for the man hug and then she,
they know according to the Nhl rule of third man in,
if there's,
if there's an altercation already happening and a third party enters it,
it's an on an automatic game misconduct.
So she should have got a game misconduct.
Right.
And if she's done that before in the past,
you know,
maybe she should get a suspension.
I'll tell you,
it was fucking hilarious.
She hung in there like a trooper.
She took knuckled and a couple of fucking elbows.
She looked like she was trying to stop one of those little kitty merry go rounds
with their head,
you know,
just kept taking a fucking bar to the skull.
Um,
he then did then did include her.
I thought it was weird that she wanted to hug with those two men.
Um,
I don't know much about Ted Cruz,
but I think,
uh,
I don't know.
I felt a weird sorta Rotisserie vibe there from his wife that I think already
occurred.
You know,
they will probably hugging saying,
all right,
we're going to do this.
Let's do it now.
Okay.
I told you I couldn't do it.
You know,
I'm running for president.
I don't need that ship.
And now it's over and I'm just a senator now,
so yeah.
You know,
I'll be on the other end where you're fucking my wife,
however,
blow me a little bit,
you know,
I don't give a shit,
just,
just push this bill through.
Isn't that how politics work?
I have no idea.
Let,
let,
let's get back to us talking about,
so fucking,
what's his name?
They're fucking a willy willful.
They're the fucking guy with the toupee comes back around again,
right?
Donald Trump.
I just want the American people to know that by giving him that fucking position
in politics,
you just cleared the way for Hillary Clinton to become president and I don't
want to hear a fucking word out of any you republicans,
not a fucking word.
This is the guy you picked.
You got no one to blame,
but just selves.
The only thing I do like about Donald Trump,
Trump actually being nominated is it makes me feel like it makes my conspiracy
theory,
like go down.
Like there's no way.
They don't count the votes.
If that guy got in,
I used to think they just pretended to count the votes and then they just stuck
this like nobody wants that fucking guy yet.
I know some of the most staunch Republicans you could possibly fucking run into
and they have their head in their hands going,
how the fuck?
How the fuck did this guy become president and I,
that's,
that's easy.
That's easy.
All you have to do is look at pop music.
He just look at the shit that sells on TV,
but your horse screaming and yelling at each other.
You know what I mean?
It's inevitable.
I have to be honest.
You,
I cannot fucking believe that this guy,
he's a fucking star of a reality show.
This is worse than when Schwartzenegger ran fucking California.
This is fucking
my God.
It's just unbelievable.
It's unfucking believable.
But anyways,
congratulations to less to city.
Um,
there must have been insane.
That's something that,
you know,
that's one of those ones you're going to talk about until you're like fucking a,
I still talk about the red sox coming back in 2004,
um,
out of all the championships,
you know,
Boston is one in the last 10 years and I can't say that 10,
12 years.
I mean,
we won a bunch of them.
Um,
that was the one that was the fucking,
you know,
it's a fucking Yankee say had like 26 championships.
We had one in like fucking 86 years down oh three.
I mean,
that was like a fucking,
it was like Jimmy Fallon Drew Barrymore,
a fucking movie there.
Right.
They actually had to throw that.
They didn't even have that in the fucking script because they were in that movie
going on on,
Nah,
this is going to seem too unbelievable.
And then it fucking happened and they had to change the ending to the movie.
That's,
that's incredible.
And um,
oh man,
I'll never forget that fucking cop if fucking New York City cop when we were
down oh three and I was still wearing my red sox hat blocking down the street in
New York and he fucking laughed.
He goes,
look at this fucking guy,
blah blah blah blah.
Just laughing.
And I remember we won the next game and the next,
next and everyday I'd walk out of my apartment going right by the same place
looking for that fucker.
And I never saw him again.
I'm like,
what was I going to do?
Point in my head,
you fucking pig and they get arrested.
That wasn't going to do that.
I would have shot him a dirty look and he would have been like,
what the fuck was that about?
Because I never had the balls to talk shit.
You know what it was.
Cause I knew he was right.
I agreed with them after game three where we lost like 19 to eight or some shit.
So anyways,
I'm congratulations.
I always love seeing shit like that when a team like that,
uh,
comes out of fucking nowhere.
So that's uh,
that's awesome.
And speaking of of sports,
believe it or not,
with my busy schedule,
I've actually,
um,
because I live on the west coast,
mercifully,
um,
I've been able to a watch most of the fucking games.
Then with the lovely Nia out of town,
I've been just living like a fucking bachelor.
Like you should see how much the Tivo or whatever the fuck he call it,
the record thing,
how much it's changed.
It was just her show her,
show her,
show her show my show her show her,
she takes fucking everything,
every motherfucking real housewife fucking thing.
She loves those shows.
Real housewives of Atlanta,
real housewives of New Jersey.
Real housewives of fucking Orange County.
Uh,
did some hip hop love show,
whatever the fuck that one's called.
And then she'll Chins,
you know,
she'll have like fucking,
I dunno,
citizen Kane,
she's one way or the other city that's just absolute fucking unbelievable.
Or,
or just like shit,
there is no middle ground with them.
Right.
And then every once in a while I'll have a game on there.
So now that she's been gone,
it's like I'm,
I'm recording every fucking game,
every fucking game.
Uh,
although I'm missing the fucking capitalism penguins right now.
Um,
but I've been watching the blues.
I've been watching the sharks.
Hey,
I'm warming up to the sharks.
I liked those bearded fuckers.
You know what?
There's something scummy about him and I don't know,
I relate to it.
Um,
I also like the pride.
I kind of like everybody who's left,
except for the penguins on the eye.
I know root against the penguins.
I just,
every time I see him,
it's like he stole our colors.
You fucking have pieces of shit and your ring of honor.
That's just something about him.
You know,
I don't hate him.
You know the reason why I don't hate them,
it's because I love Joe Bart,
Nick,
and he loves the penguin.
So I sorta fucking route forum,
but I always just think like these are the guys with the knee breakers who then
wine when people try and take their knees and I don't understand it.
They came into the league,
they took our colors.
It's just like this like room for a joke thief.
I know what they gonna say.
Oh,
you took him from you fucking Steelers.
No,
he didn't.
It was fucking hockey.
We,
we've,
we've been around since the fucking 1920s it was not fucking Pittsburgh Steelers
in 1929 I'll get,
I'll tell you right now,
I don't give a fuck if there was,
was there for me.
Actually check here.
1929 Pittsburgh.
Okay.
Steelers.
Let's see if they're around.
Doo,
Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo.
Myron copes,
Pittsburgh Steelers,
official.
Terrible tower towel.
No.
Oh,
wait a minute.
Pittsburgh Steelers,
and maybe it was,
go to Wikipedia in here.
You know,
it's funny right now,
like 99% of people in Pittsburgh now,
the answer to this question already,
there's such maniac fans.
Yeah,
I mean that in a respectful way.
Oh,
you know what?
I don't give a fuck.
God knows they're all going to correct me anyways.
I don't need to look this shit up.
Um,
but anyways,
plowing ahead here.
Uh,
I've been watching all that stuff.
Um,
I don't think that I've even though the blues or playing fucking great.
I think when Tyler's Sagan comes back,
we'll see.
We'll see what the fuck happens.
I'm going to go out on a limb here and say Dallas has a little bit of a,
a gold tender ratio.
Um,
it was a bad game.
It was a bad game for him.
Whatever.
He fucking [inaudible] plow ahead your flower head.
Um,
I believe in Jamie Ben,
they'll that guys got that fucking messy a vibe.
So I would never say that it's over until it is fucking over.
But it's looking good for the blues.
My,
uh,
my foster hockey parents since my Bruins shit,
the bed towards the end,
we didn't shut the bed.
We actually had a great fucking year for everybody we got rid of.
It's just sucks that we thought we were going to make the playoffs and we went
out west and the whole thing fell apart.
But I've talked about that before.
Hey Bill,
how's your,
how's the fucking Sayada Qca um,
like the candles.
A rock he's fucking Dean says.
Um,
so I'm actually almost a hundred percent.
I open my hundred percent because,
uh,
I got to get on a plane and I got a flight of Florida is,
I used to say as a kid and I'm doing a run of dates out there,
Hollywood,
Florida,
Orlando,
Florida in Jacksonville,
Florida.
Um,
and uh,
I think,
am I right?
These fucking stretches of the shit.
I actually tweeted a link.
Um,
if you have any sort of cyanic neuro thing,
it really helped me.
I hope it helps you.
And actually the guy who made the videos actually tweeted back to me.
So yeah,
she listens to the podcast or something,
which is fucking crazy to me.
Um,
and I guess the only other thing to tell you about is the,
uh,
is the fucking weight room that I got go.
I haven't looked at it yet today,
but um,
I finally had them show up.
You know,
I told you when we opened up the fucking see on if you saw the god Damn Weekend
Warrior Horse Shit.
You know what kills me is when I think about this house being like
almost a hundred years old,
I just think of all the people that have walked through here and shit.
You know what I mean?
Like American horror story.
And I sit there and I pictured them and I'm not afraid of them.
I'm just sort of trying to picture them and I'm trying to picture what the
fucking Douche bag.
Who did that work down there in the garage look like?
Or his friend?
I told you when we open the fucking ceiling up,
I just looked at the contract and I was just like,
what do you,
what the guy who built this,
what do you think he did for a living?
Can you think he was a mailman?
Yeah.
Was he a,
did he usually fucking a stand behind a team of oxen?
I don't know what he did,
but he sure as hell wasn't a fucking contractor.
So they finally went up there and they,
um,
yeah,
you know,
while I was at work,
I came home and they had an all fucking framed properly.
Chanel,
you don't have to worry about how fucking funny would that be?
Would it be funny for me to be funny for you guys if I finally had a gym built
in my garage and I was down there in the above,
it collapsed and killed me when I was trying to work out.
Let me ask the kind of thing that Canadian shook would say would be ironic.
Right?
And then she's so don't you think,
okay.
It's like the collapsing on you when you're working out.
Yeah.
It's getting you Paleo food.
And having no tampon.
It's one of those fucking stupid songs.
She remember when she was singing that song going,
hey,
hey ha.
When she goes down and you went to theater,
I remember I liked the song cause I liked the drums and shit.
And I remember listening to it in a fucking bar in this fucking chick just says,
do you like this side?
Even though it's a bar,
it's like I,
yeah,
I know what it's about.
I'd say she's not singing about me.
You're fucking loaded.
Tick.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
You have a glass of lemonade there.
Oh Jesus.
Don't get me started with that fucking album.
Holy Shit.
Okay.
Anyways,
what the fuck was I talking about here?
Oh Yeah,
the gym,
the gym is on fire.
This has hopefully going to be done and the next couple of weeks,
because as mentioned,
I'm sitting in the fucking writer's room and old Billy boy,
I'm maintaining,
you know,
it's funny,
I'm actually eating great during the day and then I come home and it all falls
apart because Nia is not here to say bill fucking ease up on the fucking drink
and eh,
uh,
you know,
I got those big ice cubes in the refrigerator.
I pour a couple of strong ones,
I'm feeling good.
Get off.
Next thing you know,
I'm fucking sleeping like a Goddamn grizzly.
Wake up at three in the morning,
sweating on the couch,
and then I go downstairs and I put on my pajamas.
That's basically what happens to be one of my fuck.
Well my why a wife leaves town,
you know,
Christ,
they fall apart.
Hey,
who the fuck is,
I didn't think I bought this guy before,
but Ryan Reeves on the blues,
Jesus Christ,
I don't believe they say he's six one two 30 something.
When he's out there,
he looks like he's six five to 60
guys like the fucking hulk on skates.
He looks like an even bigger George La rock.
I love when he was like sort of backing into the boards and he just punches
three different fucking stars right in the face.
Just sort of face wash is this guy a little jab for you?
A is a fucking leave fucking,
you know,
shake you around like a rag doll.
Then he blows a kiss to the bench.
That was shades of John when sync,
way back in the day when he challenged the whole,
um,
north stars bench as somebody to fucking step over
Jesus,
he looked like a fucking lunatic.
Okay.
You know what I mean?
He looks like that guy.
Like,
yeah,
it just doesn't,
you know,
it goes to pick up a child and accidentally kills him.
There was a lot of guys I played in the Nhl in the 70s.
He just looked at him like,
you know,
Dave Schultz,
the fucking looks on their faces sometimes when they went out there.
Granted they had to do what they had to do,
but there's a lot of those guys,
you know,
they,
they really should have been in jail.
Um,
and I hate to say this,
but that,
that is what really attracted me to the sport.
It was always,
it was the fighting first.
Okay.
And for the,
for the life of me,
I don't understand why people have a problem with it.
You know what I mean?
I hate when people talk about the purity of sport in the purity of competition
and all of that.
It's just like,
just shot.
I mean,
why don't you just fucking look up the chimney and wait for Santa Claus to come
down?
You know what I mean?
Purity and sports,
the whole fucking,
the whole,
at least here in the United States,
I mean,
the whole fucking thing.
Okay.
It's like that poor bastard we've got caught.
Was He smoking fucking dope?
He's supposed to do that.
He's in college.
Right.
And then,
you know,
he gets a couple of hundred bucks.
He's playing for a team that's selling like 80,000 to 100,000 tickets a fucking
week and he doesn't get to fucking nickels to rub together.
Okay.
And what,
what are the odds that he's actually going to make it?
Don't even fucking tell me,
oh,
he gets a free education.
He doesn't have time to study.
He's got to study the fucking playbook,
right?
Yeah.
That's slave labor,
man.
It's fucking,
they're all getting,
they're getting fucked over.
I get some point.
They really got to do like the,
uh,
sort of like the college athlete behind the music.
Like,
and I'm not talking about the guys that made it then got fucked over,
you know,
with people's,
relative stealing their money.
Just about all those fucking people that you just,
you went to school,
you didn't have time to go to class.
The team you were playing on was selling out the fucking arena.
It actually paid for the most of the buildings on the campus.
And then,
uh,
you didn't make it.
And now go ahead and,
well,
now you're driving a fucking,
you some six foot 10 guy driving a bus,
you know,
driving the fucking Ava's shuttle.
They could have at least,
you know.
Okay,
Sean up a little bit of money.
Do you understand me?
Just as a performer,
all I could say is,
you know,
to go out there and fucking sell a thousand,
100,000 seats,
I can't imagine how much fucking money that is.
Can't imagine it and forget about all the fucking march,
all of that shit.
They can't kick the,
this guy's gonna,
they're gonna break this guy's balls over like 500 box.
Um,
I don't know.
I think it's bullshit,
but I'm also,
I'm also pretty jaded,
so maybe,
maybe I'm,
I can do this right now.
Am I gonna fuck him retract again?
Maybe I'm wrong.
I'm sorry.
I shouldn't have said that.
Donald Trump's a great,
you know,
he's a great,
uh,
it's a great choice out of all the Americans out there that you could have
picked,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
Let's have Donald Trump against Hillary Clinton and fucking,
uh,
Barry Sanders coming up around the outside.
It's fuck's his name will not Larry Sanders,
Bernie Sanders.
Um,
oh.
What are you going to do?
This is just going to be a brutal eight years.
Hey,
how bout a Bama fucking killing it?
That's the second time he's done that.
He murdered at some other fucking banquet.
Um,
that time took the piss out of fucking Donald Trump.
And some people are saying that's why Donald ended up running.
But uh,
I have no idea.
Maybe they just trying to blame him for the fucking nightmare.
That is Donald Trump.
I cannot fucking believe that there wasn't anybody in the Republican Party that
could defeat this guy.
My only fucking thing as I watch Hillary go to the White House,
then I'm going to with joy is watching him be a fucking asshole to her.
Um,
I just hope that he treats her the way he treated all the guys I want.
I want gloves off.
I want to bring it up fucking every skeleton they have.
That's going to be the only enjoyment then I'm going to get out of this cause
other than,
yeah,
it's a fucking travesty.
But Hey,
at least you know,
you can't say now that they don't count the votes because there's no fucking way
anybody have influenced once that guy,
there's no fucking way.
You know,
this is actually becoming personal,
like the level with which then I'm fucking talking about this guy.
So I guess I got to trash.
I got trash.
Hillary.
I've trashed her enough.
Bernie Sanders,
the old man on the lawn,
right?
I Dunno.
So anyways,
um,
I'm going to do a little bit advertising here and uh,
you guys have a wonderful weekend.
You can't a marine a little bit advertising here and then we're going to play
some fucking music and then play a little bit of a,
some greatest hits from back in the day on the podcast.
And uh,
you know,
I'm sure there'll be a couple of you bitching about it.
Music,
there's always people bitch,
who the fuck cause you don't use you go,
you like music tonight?
All lawyers.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
all right.
I don't have the advertising right now.
So this is going to be a weird thing where now we have to stop and then it's
going to cut back on.
So I'm hitting stop right now.
And by the wonder of technology or whatever stuff.
Editing of garage band.
I don't know.
I'll be back in like a second.
So there's really no reason to even bring it up.
All right.
The magic of a technology here.
I'm actually watching the end of the capitals.
Pittsburgh game to 20,
40.
Go in this third.
It's all tied up there.
Alright,
a little bit of advertising here.
All right,
this is from on it.
Uh,
for my good friend Joe Rogan.
Joe Rogan swears by this stuff.
Everybody Alpha brain instant from on.
It is a delicious all natural stimulant free drink mix that help support memory,
focus and processing speed.
The Boston Medical Center.
Now the Boston Santa for memory,
I need some of this shit's so bad.
Conducted a double blind study showing its effectiveness.
What they should do is have me read this shit now and then take someone,
watch me cry later.
Um,
it's the secret weapon of pro athletes like Bodie Miller and Duncan Keith,
but anyone can benefit from the effects of Alpha brain instant.
Simply mix of a stick packet of Alpha brain instant into a water bottle bottle
and start feeling the effects immediately.
It's non GMO gluten free,
stimulant free made of natural ingredients.
And most importantly it works as a special offer for my listeners.
You can try Alpha brain instant for free by going to [inaudible] dot com slash
bill that's o n n I t.com/bird to get your free sample of Alpha brain instant
now.
Oh Jesus,
look Uzbek club Debbie,
everybody club.
Damn.
Can't clip Jimmy out.
Why didn't you vote for GM?
Now you can.
Don't Trump love wine.
Sure.
We all do.
We've got the perfect wine club for you club Debbie.
It's good to Afghanistan.
BMC each month war.
Um,
club w was a revolutionary wine club that delivers high quality wine straight to
your door.
They partner with innovative,
they partner with innovative wine makers from all over the world,
world,
world to produce a wide variety of small lot handcrafted wines for them.
Members with club.
Debbie,
I got nothing else to say about GM.
I'm a fishing on an aquifer.
Um,
you have the freedom to pick up and choose the types of wines and the number of
bottles you receive each month.
Right now club Debbie Hallock of weapons of mass destruction is offering
listeners $20 off your first order when you go to club.
Debbie,
my daughters used to be drunk horse and now they're married club w.
Dot com slash burn after that,
against the even.
Fuck it.
I know you all hate paying for shipping.
So club Debbie will actually pay for your shipping on orders of bottles,
four bottles or more.
So take something off your to do list.
Just go to club Debbie at.com/burr to get $20 off your first order.
Now that's club debbie.com/burr.
All right.
Uh,
what do we got here?
Boll and branch,
Boll and branch.
Um,
it sounds like a steakhouse as you set out to improve yourself.
There's one simple thing you can do everyday to help you be your best in every
situation.
And that's get a good night's sleep.
Don't I know it?
Fucking booze bag.
Boll and branch delivers the rest you need wrapped up in their super comfortable
luxury linens and they do it right there.
The first bedding company to be fair trade certified,
which means your sheets come from the work of happy hands,
not from sweatshops.
That's really interesting.
It's great to see a company do that,
huh?
And beautiful packaging made entirely from recycled and sustainable materials.
Let me listen to my shirt right now.
I can hear the fucking child crying that put it together.
Um,
are okay.
You can only get the sheets in one place.
That's and branch.com where you know you're paying for quality and not
department store overhead.
You're getting thousand dollars sheets for just a couple of hundred bucks.
Go to boll and branch,
that's B o l l and branch.com and they'll treat you,
they'll let you try them.
Risk fee,
three for 30 nights.
If you don't love them,
you can send them back.
You have nothing to lose and it gets even better.
Go to Boll and branch.com today for 20% off your entire order sheets,
towels,
blankets,
and do VA covers everything.
Plus free shipping and all their products come beautifully packaged and the
signature boxes go to bolden branch.com today for 20% off your entire order and
use Promo Code,
Burr Boll and branch.com Promo Code Burr Boll and branch.com Promo Code Burr.
And lastly,
but certainly not leastly tracker.
Oh pens and fucking caps go to overtime.
All right.
Trackers,
smart cars,
smart phones,
SMAD homes,
technology as everything,
Matt,
but losing your stuff sucks man.
It makes smart people feel stupid.
Tracker makes losing things.
A thing of the past tracker is a coin size device that's put in the base of your
brain.
Now that's locates this kid and this plays keys,
wallets,
bags,
computers,
anything in seconds,
just pair of tracker to your smartphone,
attach it to anything and find precise location with the tap of a button.
It's that easy.
Lose your phone.
No problem.
Press the button on tracker.
Bam.
There's your phone.
Oh,
there it is right out of my ass.
Even when it's on silent,
you can still hear it.
All right with over 1.5 million devices tracker has the largest crowd gps
network in the world.
So your last item shows up on a map.
Even if it's miles away,
never lose anything.
Again with tracker listeners to this show,
get a special discount of 30% off your entire order.
Go to the tracker.com t h e tracker.com and enter the Promo code [inaudible].
The hardest thing you'll ever have to do is find their website.
Go to the tracker doc,
go to to the tracker.com right now and enter the Promo code birth for 30% off
your entire order.
Again,
that's the t h e tracker.com Promo Code Birth.
All right,
with that,
here's some music
and some throwbacks back,
uh,
podcast stuff there,
right?
I'll change
[inaudible]
hey,
what's going on
Monday morning podcast,
but I'm going to be doing it my dentist fucking hybrid cause I got a ton of shit
to do today.
Right out of the back.
You know this is going to be an edgy one.
Scares me a little pollen in my throat.
My car looks like shit.
I'm getting it fixed this week,
getting a dent taken out.
It cost me 800 bucks,
which my insurance company,
but all they're going to do is charge me more money,
which really makes you wonder why the fuck he have insurance.
Insurance is one of the biggest scams out there.
In fact,
I remember a long time ago buddy of mine was working in insurance when I first
started realizing what a fucking scam it was.
I was living in Boston at the time and he said to me,
he goes,
Bill,
what are the two tallest buildings in Boston?
And I was like,
God,
the John Hancock building and the Prudential Center.
It goes.
Exactly,
exactly.
Do you think they're paying out fucking money to people than not?
You know,
we meet,
go watch that fucking spike Lee thing on New Orleans.
Um,
all right.
Jesus Christ.
Let me ordering people around.
Um,
anyways,
I got a lot of questions and advice last week when I was waiting for that
plumber to come fix my stinky sync.
And um,
a lot of people,
first of all want to know if the plumber ever showed up well.
Well first,
let me give you the backstory here.
For those of you who didn't listen to her last week,
I'll give you a little bit of last week's episode.
Like one of those old Batman TV shows from the 60s.
Uh,
last week,
uh,
plummer was supposed to come at 9:00 AM to look at my sink because for some
reason the water coming out of the spout of the Faucet,
um,
smells like swamp ass.
I don't know why.
Started vaguely smelling like shit.
And as the weeks progressed,
all of a sudden it was just,
it was disgusting.
It's not like literally a slumped mount,
like an APP that was dipped in a swamp after somebody.
Joe.
All right,
let's not,
let's not get too disgusting.
It's not terrible.
Right?
So this mother fucker was supposed to show up at 9:00 AM
when I started doing my podcast,
I believe it was about 10 oh three not to get anal,
that's trying to get anal here.
But uh,
yeah,
he still hadn't showed up.
So basically,
you know,
I was trashing him.
I was trashing other plumbers,
the entire art of plumbing.
I was trashing.
So a lot of people ask me,
because at the end of my podcast,
the guy had not shown up.
And Long Story Short,
about 20 minutes after my podcast,
um,
I had to do something that people do in a bathroom.
So I went in there and God damn,
and I did because I'm a fucking American,
wouldn't,
Ya know,
one,
two,
three minutes after I finished doing what is my God given,
right as a fucking American with a bathroom that I pay to use the fucking knock
at the door.
Who is it?
The goddamn plumber.
And I'm like,
you gotta be shitting me.
Okay.
I didn't light a match.
There was no incense.
I didn't burn a newspaper or a fucking,
you know,
been let it trashcan on fire.
You know,
like I was going to sink some Doo wop with three of my other friends.
It was just been,
they're all natural and uh,
I dunno,
I just panic for half a second.
Then I just hit this moment of then like,
you know what,
I don't give a fuck.
So he comes walking in after already finding out that,
uh,
you know,
reading this little report that I said my six smelt like swamp ass.
And he comes walking in there and I'm thinking maybe,
maybe I'll be lucky.
Three minutes has gone by.
I eat a pretty healthy diet.
Maybe,
uh,
maybe the smell left and whatever.
And he walked in,
said,
he goes,
Jesus Christ.
He goes,
is that the smell coming out of the sink?
And the old me would have panicked at that point,
but I didn't.
I just hit him with straight up honesty.
Hey listen.
I said,
listen man,
I gotta be honest with you.
You know,
you're supposed to be here an hour and a half ago.
I didn't think he was showing up.
So I took a dump and the guy,
he goes,
oh,
no worries.
No worries dude.
Just shrugged it off.
You know,
like somebody on the vice squad seeing a body,
you think smelling a little bit of shifts enough to scare a fucking plumber.
I've got news for you because I lived at last week.
And anyway,
it's turned out to be,
I had this filter on my,
on my sink,
I get some bacteria had built up and Yada Yada Yada.
What the fuck?
It's all good.
So,
uh,
so the guy didn't show up and uh,
there was a potentially awkward moment that I diffuse must speak.
He always got to go with honesty even when it's uh,
uh,
discussing one and wow,
that was just one big shit joke story wasn't it?
But um,
I actually got a lot of advice,
a one for my uh,
particular plumber and he was saying he hit some people out there in case your
Ra,
the water coming out of your faucet smells like swamp ass.
Okay.
If you have a filter on there,
change that.
Got them filter.
Cause that might be if,
and if not,
this plumber says sometimes it's easy to change the whole faucet when you're
dealing with that kind of smell.
Stay away from the home depot faucets.
The plastic in them eventually cracks and leaks from somewhere.
I like wolverine brass,
but anything with brass internal should be fine.
So they could go you like that?
You knew what to my podcast,
this is what I do.
I tell stories in my life that,
and it invariably end up being a big ship joke story and uh,
you know,
people listen to them and then I get information,
I try to pass it onto you.
Then he'd go,
that's,
that's from an actual plumber who was also upset that the plumber didn't show
up.
Because I hate when people do shit like that.
Right.
I know why it gives him a bad reputation.
Evidently this is one of the good ones.
You know,
Kinda like one of those by the book crops that you see that 20 minutes into the
movie have to turn in their badge if they continue to work the case and then
they solve it using extreme force,
you know,
doing billion dollars worth of damage to the city
fucking skyscape or whatever the hell you call it.
What the hell do you call that skyline?
Skyscape I really am an asshole.
So they go,
yeah,
seven down.
What you want to use a,
you want to use some breath?
He said something about measuring the spread between the,
the uh,
the nozzles on the faucet and that's some shit I'm going to,
I'm going to remember to say that next time I go into a hardware store because
he said I might get fucked over if I walk in there and look in the way.
I do like a squeaky clean comic who takes a dump in a bathroom five minutes
before the plumber shows up.
It's not my fault.
He was late.
All right,
here we go.
So anyways,
if you knew one of my podcasts,
like I said,
I give information about upcoming gigs.
Don't take a left in front of me.
Yeah,
yeah.
Welcome to America.
We wait for the other guy two weeks now,
but there is a right away La.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
Let me get through this part here.
I'm trying to navigate through traffic here.
Yeah,
I answer.
People send me questions.
Um,
they might have about anything from a,
when's your next gig too?
How do you fix the sink,
which I pass onto one of my 15 listeners.
I'm up to 1515 listeners.
One evidently of whom is a plumber.
So if you have any questions,
just email them to me.
Please tell people about this podcast so I can get the number up over 20 and uh,
and that's it.
So first off,
let me hype what I've got coming up
the next episode up uninformed with Joe de Rosa.
My radio show with Joe to Rosa on Xm two o two is going to be a this Saturday
night.
Well I think it's the Saturday,
May 24th.
I don't have a calendar in front of me.
Um,
May 24th,
uh,
it's going to be on Xm two o two from 9:00 PM to 12:00 AM we have a anger
management therapist coming in and those of you who listened to our show
realized that me and Joe Yell at each other a lot.
We tend to call each other cunts and we're trying to do a little less of that on
the show.
So whatever the lady came on,
it was a great show.
And a Joe also recently split with his longtime girlfriend,
so he had a lot of,
a lot of pain.
Let it tear shed.
So anyways,
listen to what XM two o to the uninformed show.
May 24th 9:00 PM to 12:00 AM with bill burr and Joe to Rosa.
All right,
there you go.
And as far as upcoming gigs go,
um,
I'm actually coming back to New York for one day this week we're going to be one
of the comics on Jim Norton standup show on Hbo,
going to be doing 10 minutes of comedy and a that's going to be showing in
airing in September,
I believe.
So,
uh,
I'm actually this week trying to figure out what 10 minutes I'm going to do.
Um,
and other than that,
I'm going to be a Caroline's comedy club on May 29th through June 1st Charlie
Goodnight's June 5th through the eighth and June 19th through the 21st I'll be
at the punch line in Atlanta.
All of the takes I have up on my site except for the ones that I haven't put
down yet because I'm disorganized.
And then you'd go
anyways,
back to the podcast here.
I want to thank everybody who came out to see me at [inaudible] and I Chicago.
I went to a cubs game on Thursday and fucking sucked one of the best ballpark
there ever was.
And every time it's like a fourth time going to a game out there.
And every time I go out there,
I'm always out there in April and May because I'm either doing a college or for
some reason that's when I get booked at xannies and I always go out there and
it's like fucking 40 degrees out and
there's barely any ivy on the wall and I feel like I'm at a bare skin just
freezing my fucking ass off.
Turned the collar up on my coat.
Like I'm going to commit a crime at a God damn baseball game.
I'm wearing my leather coat with the fur inside.
Like come on Barney Miller and it got the baseball game.
I really feel bad for you people out there and Straub.
We have such a beautiful city that was a school bus.
I was a school bus.
It just went by and almost took my fucking arm off.
Um,
you know,
such a beautiful God city,
but that,
whether it's just that,
that Lake Michigan man,
it's like this is giant fan.
It's just pointed at that city constantly.
All right,
that went nowhere.
Whatever.
I went to a great baseball stadium and it fucking sucked because it was a,
you know,
really sucked was where I was sitting.
It was just open.
Uh,
what'd he call aisle way in the new ballparks.
They wait until a stoppage of play before they let people walk by,
which I bitched about in the past because I never had the seats right behind the
aisle.
They fucking horrific.
I've never seen so much food.
There's so many food and beer vendors.
What by every five fucking seconds,
I missed so many God damn place because,
because it was cotton candy guy,
it's like 40 degrees out.
This guy's walking around with this big stick,
you know,
you know how they do it.
They got like that,
uh,
you know,
and they don't want you to steal a shopping cart and they got that big long pole
going up the top of it.
He's got one of those.
And on the end of it,
you've got all this fucking cotton candy.
All right?
It's like four feet across,
walking around like a fucking Hobo,
a diabetic,
Hobo,
and he keeps walking by.
Hey,
cut and candy.
It's like too,
nobody's buying cotton candy all write a fucking four year old,
buys it after he gets up at Ferris wheel.
No one buys it at a fucking baseball game when it's 40 degrees out.
Go get some pretzels
or peanut,
some shit that fits you waste that are walking around like we don't see it.
It's fucking Tutti.
Frutti we see it
can't be all right.
Here we go.
Podcast questions.
Uh,
do you enjoy living in Los Angeles or do you regret moving?
Well,
as you can obviously hear from the joy of this podcast,
I'm having the time of my life.
Actually.
No,
I don't.
I don't regret moving out here.
I actually,
for the most part,
I love living out here.
Up until yesterday where I started to feel the beginning of the summer desert
heat and I got to admit I'm getting a little scared.
It's a,
like they say,
it's definitely a dry heat,
but it's a way to describe desert heat oven.
Ask
as if to say like,
I don't know,
you're cooking something.
He'd get your forearm too close to the oven and you just feel what it feels like
to be a slowly roasted.
That's what it feels like it.
And I'm also into the environment,
so I very rarely use my air conditioner.
So right now my victor Wooten tee shirt is stuck to my back,
but I'm going to plow through this here.
So no,
I don't regret moving out here.
It has been a great experience.
Definitely was an adjustment and I still own a place back in New York,
so I have that little Linus blanket in my back pocket anytime.
I don't want to be out here.
I'll fucking crush up my hybrid like an old tuna can and I'll recycle it and
I'll move back.
All right,
number two,
I know you like conspiracy theories,
so what's your take on John F.
Kennedy assassination,
do you think?
KILLED JFK?
I watched the mythbusters show one time.
They reenacted the magic bullet and we're actually able to recreate it.
Okay.
Where are they?
Where are they really able to fucking recreate the magic bullet?
Yes.
Kind of easy to do that when he got a camera crew and fucking editing and all
that crap.
What do I think?
Um,
I think what everybody thinks.
I think,
uh,
you know,
I think a lot more people were involved.
Um,
I dunno what,
what do I know?
I don't know.
I think,
uh,
I think basically to become president,
you got to get in bed with a lot of shady people and if you go into the office,
you turn your back on them.
Um,
you're going for a ride in a convertible.
That's what I think.
I Dunno.
Obviously Oswald didn't do it or they wouldn't,
they,
they mean,
or at least didn't do it by himself,
but they wouldn't have all that stuff ain't out on the top secret papers there.
God that I just sound angry,
ignorant,
you know,
I couldn't even say ignorant.
All right.
I Dunno.
I don't know who the fuck did it,
but you know,
Jesus Christ is fucking boss.
Go ahead,
go
the hell are they advertising on the back?
L Kooky,
Kooky television.
So I had to learn how to speak Spanish,
man.
It's,
it's the last fucking thing I do.
I sweat it.
God,
some of that Spanish TV,
the women that are on it,
I,
some of the most beautiful women I've ever seen in my life and they always got
those fucking
like three inch stiletto heels on.
And what I love about Latin women is like you trust an American girl up like
that.
She looked like she was getting whored out and it's somehow on those Telemundo
shows those girls are dressed like whores,
but somehow they own it,
they own it and their vibe is more like,
yeah,
I know I look good and you'll never get this.
It probably also helps that they always have some fat 45 year old sort of used
car looking salesman host standing next to it and he's always giggling the way
I'd be giggling if I was standing next to him except I wouldn't have a jet black
mustache.
All right,
next question,
Bill.
There were some corn ball names for comedy clubs.
Giggles.
Bananas,
Loony Bin,
the funny bone.
If you owned a comedy club,
what would you,
what would you name it?
Uh,
I dunno.
Slap happy.
You know what?
I tried to give it a dignified name.
Uh,
Winston's
and
elegant night of comedy and Hilarious.
I don't know what the fuck I would call it.
You know what the reality is,
is that there's no good name for a comedy club.
I'm trying to think of one punch line.
Punch line is a good one.
Giggles stinks.
I really takes any sort of credible credibility away from your,
like people are going to be putting their hands up like I'm one of those bad
Asian horror movies.
Um,
or maybe the porno,
not the horn.
I'll move Cornell.
Not the horror movies.
I can't even fucking talk.
Breathing in this.
God damn buses,
gas fumes.
I think I just invented a new genera film.
Cornell.
She was Hora and porn or not.
That's a fucking smudge film.
All right.
Everything's been done.
God dammit.
I can't come up with an original idea.
All right,
completely unrelated question,
but I was wondering what your favorite music is.
A,
what kind of you listened to Jesus fucking Christ.
Like I almost fucking slammed right into me.
Wow.
Matching that and his like died on my podcast,
but I had like the energy to hit pound right before I died.
And so actually,
uh,
you know what,
that would suck then I'd actually finally sell out a fucking club.
Jesus Christ.
That was so scary as fuck.
I forgot the question.
What are some of my favorite,
what am I listening to right now?
I'm actually listening to Jimi Hendrix,
a band of Gypsies,
specifically that song machine gun,
which I really like.
Google it.
Google it or whatever.
Youtube and I watched Jimmy play it.
Please don't watch John Mayer.
Okay.
As he runs through the halls of his high school playing fucking Jimi Hendrix is
Dennis Miller mullet.
Jesus Christ.
What the fuck am I lashing out at him?
You know why?
Because I'm trying to make a right turn.
The wind is blowing through my hybrid and it's blowing my little fucking sheet
music.
But I like to call the podcast questions on,
on my lap.
Wow.
I'm going to finish finish the rest of this podcast and my garage,
like I'm going to commit suicide.
It's one of the great things about the hybrid is it's going to switch over to
electricity so I don't have to worry about the films,
which is actually,
I saw somebody do a bit about that.
All right.
And we hit the power button and it is off.
That's the great thing about a hybrid.
You literally shut it off like a fucking radio.
All right.
Winding down if people stay with me.
All right,
number six.
Are you the same bill bird that was in the movie?
Passionata if so,
what kind of part did you have?
I've never seen the movie,
but I saw that a bill burr was on the castless.
Yes,
that is me.
I wasn't that movie.
And I had a quick scene.
I played a guy at a black check blackjack table with actually the guy who was in
the movie.
The Patriot played the,
uh,
the general there I guess,
which was,
it was really over the top bad version of a,
I guess a red coat and people in England got upset about it because,
uh,
because that's not who they are over in England.
You know,
I think if you've read a history book,
you look at the long wonderful line of diplomacy that has been England's foreign
policy.
Um,
you can understand why they would get upset by the movie,
the Patriot and why they're so upset with America and our foreign policy.
Because I know if any country out there would be upset by another country going
in and invading a country and oppressing gets people who would be England
because God knows they don't fucking stand for that shit.
Yes.
This is dripping with sarcasm and this is coming from all the youtube videos.
I see where you sit there and you see all these English people who were on that
Goddamn high horse now because England,
so I can,
you know,
fourth place around the world now they can act like a,
like the,
like,
they're like these fucking live aid people.
Let me tell you something to my one listener who's from fucking England,
if you hate America right now,
the reason why you should hate us is because of plagiarism,
because we stole your ideas and it's how we now have our world empire,
which will eventually fall.
And um,
all right,
take it up.
You fucking high horses.
Okay?
You guys have created more goddamned evil out there and we're just,
you just pass the baton to us now.
It's our turn to be evil and you guys are fucking fat too.
All right.
I've seen that show.
You are,
when you eat motherfuckers over there having pork chops and fry ups for
breakfast,
you know,
so go fuck yourself and uh,
go fuck yourselves and fuck man,
United.
Got Damn Yankees of soccer.
All right,
there you go.
Wow.
It's a little bit of anger there.
Okay.
Um,
not that I even give a shit.
Okay,
so don't send me some bad message that ends with mate
in it.
That's it.
I'm now back in my past.
And you like that.
You got to hear me walk up the fucking stairs.
You've heard the garage door closed.
You really get let into my life here.
This is like my own reality show,
except it's not on television and there's no advertising money.
Other than that,
I'm making a fortune.
All right.
[inaudible].